This holiday season, Instacart is bringing magic to the people who make it magic for others. Get delivery and deals on everything you need this season. Whether it's a last-minute holiday decor emergency, coverage for the holiday party, or just avoiding going out in the cold, Instacart is here. Plus, with no markups at select retailers, you get in-store prices on grocery, electronics, beauty, toys, and more. Download the Instacart app to get a little magic delivered today. Instacart, groceries that over deliver. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together, and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week, we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. This is cool cat that I hang out with at Christmas Never knew how to pronounce his last name Good king when Silas looked out On the feast of Stephen When the snow lay round about Deep and crisp and even
Brightly shown the moon that night Though the frost was cruel When a poor man came in sight Gathering winter fuel Woo-hoo! Happy holidays, everyone! Happy holidays! We are listening to a song on the album, A Swing and Little Christmas by Jane Lynch and Kate Flannery, our guest here today. Hey!
Kate, welcome. Oh, my gosh, you are putting me in the holiday spirit. I'll try not to sing everything today. So good to see you guys. It's so good to see you. Thank you. Thank you for joining us on our holiday chit-chat episode. Here's what we're going to do today, everyone.
We are going to talk about the holidays on the office. we're going to talk about holidays in general, all kinds of other stuff. We're so excited to have you, Kate, and you have dressed for the occasion. You took the assignment. You're like, I'm on it, ladies. You look amazing. Thank you so much. I do not phone it in, even on a podcast.
I bring it 300%. You're coming in hot, lady. I love anyone that embraces a theme. I was like, you know what? Come on. We're talking about Christmas. I mean, every Christmas party, if anybody's ever worked in any kind of establishment that had, a party once a year in December, you know, you know what's going on. We got to celebrate.
You got your outfit. I mean, I might have worn red velvet pants to a Christmas party one time. You got your cute little. I have my Christmas sweater on. Your Christmas sweater with your mini Cooper with a Christmas tree on top. You too could wear this if you went to Marshall's last year. And Jenna's got her black watch plaid jacket with Christmas earrings. My Christmas earrings that you said look like Christmas earrings that Meredith wore. Meredith wore. They look like Christmas balls that she literally like the tiny ones that you take off the tree
and you try to put in your ear when you're younger and realize it's a bad idea. The same Christmas balls that Angela Martin smashed in the snow and screeched. Yeah. Your tart and jacket is super cute. Okay. Lady, you gave me that tartan jacket. I know, I know I did. Do you remember because you compliment it today as if you'd never seen it before?
No, I do. We have matching ones. I bought myself one as well. You both have great taste. Thank you. Our do I. Right now, because that's what we're thinking. So let's say it.
But it's true. They're so cute. Well, listen, let's get to it. We're so excited to have you. Thank you, guys. I'm so excited to be here. Office ladies forever. That's right.
And we are going to kick things off with a question from Cindy. Let's hear from her. Hi, this is Cindy from Fort Worth. And I'd love to hear how you get ready for the holidays. All right. How do we get ready for the holidays, ladies? Well, for me, I actually tour every holiday, every December. Well, actually, right after Thanksgiving.
So I have to put my stuff up before Thanksgiving or late Thanksgiving night. I tour with Jane Lynch because we did a Christmas album 10 years ago. And so we just, you know, keep like we're very busy in December. We're bringing Christmas to people. It's a huge responsibility. It's so great, though. Your show is wonderful. I have been.
It's such a blast. Yeah, like I did a Christmas concert. It's our album, A Swinging Little Christmas, if you can't see it in person. But you know what? But it's fun. I feel like it forces me to do it early because I always want to come home and I would feel terrible if my place didn't look like Christmas when I got home. So I have to step it up. You have to decorate before you go on tour. I have to because I'd be so bummed when I came home and be like, oh. Also, your tour is how other people can get ready for the holidays. This is true. And people do. Yeah, usually we're like the first thing that they're seeing for the holidays because we literally start the day after Thanksgiving. I play your CD. I still have a CD. You might not have to get a new car. An album.
I played your Christmas album, I should say. You know what I mean? Yes. Because we're on Spotify and iTunes, but it's so great. It's fun. It's fun to listen to. I know. I'm just like, I actually have it on vinyl too, you guys. Oh.
Limited edition on vinyl. Oh, can I get one of those? Because we play records on Christmas morning. Yeah. Let me talk to my people. Talk to your people because Jack plays records for us. Yes. Because his bedroom's right off the kitchen, he cranks it.
We'll make it happen. And maybe if he becomes a DJ, he can, Looka, wika, wika, wika. Well, for me, getting ready for the holidays is putting up the tree. That's when I feel like things have started and I feel festive. But my hot tip is you don't have to do it all in the same day. Because for us, we have a faky tree, okay? And it's out in the shed.
And that means we've got to dig it out and dig out all the ornaments and all my throw pillows. I love a festive throw pillow. Just give it to me. I mean, you're saying that is if you don't also love a festive throw I wrote blanket. Exactly. I have Christmas blankets spitting. Anyway, so you dig it. Where does it end, Angela? Where does? This is an intervention. I know. I have my Christmas. I'm here. I have my Christmas village. I get very excited about. I love your village. It's so cute. And the kids help me. It does. And the kids set it all out. But anyway, what I've learned is that if we try to do it all in one day, someone has a meltdown. Always, always. And it's usually Josh. Because he's the one that's to dig everything out. So he's like, like, let's just get it all out. I'll get the tree up. And then we're done. And then we decorate the next day. So that's how we do it. That sounds very sensible. Yeah. And usually Christmas is not very sensible for most people. You feel like a child and you have to do it the way your mother did
somewhere. That's so true, right? I live and grew up in a household where we only got the tree a couple days before because we always had a real tree. So if you get it too early, it's, you know, then you can't leave it up until the end of January. I know. Exactly. Yeah. It's true. But that's such a good point, like managing the traditions that you grew up with versus the traditions that actually work for your life. Yeah. Like, it wouldn't work for you to wait. No, I get home too late. Exactly.
I usually fly to Philadelphia. I've seen my family. You know, yeah, yeah, I'm like, I'm all over the place. It's crazy. But I love the fact that you're figuring out the sanity. Whatever you need to do. Whatever you need to do. This, when you put your tree up is a hot debate online.
I don't know if you know this. People get real, like, strong opinions about it. and I read a survey in good housekeeping. Do you want to know what I said? Yeah, please. Okay, most folks put up their tree at some point between December 2nd and December 23rd. But they also found that a common theme is that one and four people say they put up their tree on December 1st. But they did note that putting up a Christmas tree and decorating it is becoming an earlier and earlier tradition.
I know people who put their trees up before Thanksgiving. You know, my mom has to put up her. tree before Thanksgiving because when we go home to visit, we visit on Thanksgiving. We don't visit on Christmas, but we celebrate Christmas. We do a thanksmas. One day is Thanksgiving. One day is Christmas. See, I'm fascinated by this. Yes. Yes. So she puts up all her Christmas decorations in time for Thanksgiving so that we can go and open gifts in a festive manner. Oh, I like that. I know some people that never take down their lights ever all year round. And that's okay. And that's Is it? I don't know. Is it? Okay. Here's my, wait, I saw something. I saw like a meme online or something
that was like the great thing about November. Oh my God, am I going to, I'm butchering it. But they were like, the great thing about November is you see the, forget it. You see the transition. Don't give up. Oh my God. Okay. You got this. It was like, it was like something like the great thing about November is you see all the people in your neighborhood who have left up their Halloween decorations. And then all the people who already have Christmas up, and you can see very clearly who's type A and type B in your neighborhood. And you can make a note for later. That is very funny.
That's hilarious. I do judge if it's like mid-November and you have a few skeletons in the front yard, I'm like, get it together. Exactly. My brief six months living in Brooklyn, they would literally be cobwebs on the pilgrims on people's lawns, which I was like, oh, wow, you actually got pilgrims for Thanksgiving, which I thought was ambitious. But they kind of doubled up on Halloween and Thanksgiving at the same time, which I don't
You know, I mean, it's interesting. It's an interesting part of the brain that I don't have. Zombie Pilgrims. I don't want to tell people what to do, but I started decorating a good amount of my Halloween decorations are just sort of like pumpkins and fall. And then I sprinkle in a few skeletons. And then when you take the skeletons away, boom. I already do the same thing.
I do the same thing. Yeah. I think that's the. It's like a double decorating. It's a double deck. Yeah. Okay, wait. Multitasking.
One last. One last tidbit from good housekeeping, because I thought this was interesting. So, you know, in ye olden times, like way, way back, ye olden times, Christmas decorations wouldn't be put up until the last possible moment because people decorated their trees with edible items like gingerbread, chocolates, other sweets. They were all hung on the branches with ribbon. And that continued into the Victorian times. Most people didn't put up their tree until, like, Christmas Eve to preserve the trees.
Totally. And actually, in my family, I remember. My parents, when they first got married, they used to do that. And then when my, I'm one of seven kids, so my oldest sister is like, you know, 13 and a half years older than me. So when they were little, they would go to sleep Christmas Eve with no tree and then wake up and it was like, what? So it was like Santa brought the tree.
That's what I was going to say. Wasn't there a thing for a while where Santa brought the tree? Could you imagine as a parent? Oh, my gosh. In addition to everything else, you have to decorate, you're putting together like a whole tree up with food on it? Yeah, while you're assembling a dollhouse and, you know, waiting, but, I mean, you got to wait for Santa for the rest of it. But boy, you really got to, you got to have Santa's cookies, you gotta do it, right?
Wow. It's, yeah, another reason to drink, you guys. You'll always find a reason. Meredith is here. You know, my dad had a bar, so, you know, the apple doesn't fall far from the alcoholic tree. This is not true about you in real life. You're like one of the most sensible people. You know, if I get invited, I'm usually.
You are fun, but incredibly responsible. But I do have to ask you, Jenna, because I know you guys have traditions in St. Louis, and now I've learned about thanks Christmas. Is that how you say it? Thanks, Miss. It's so easy. You're saying you've learned about it. I've told you about thanksmas a million times.
No, no, no, no. I know the tradition. I didn't know you called it thanksmas. I've talked about it on the podcast before. You've never called it thanksmas. I have. It's okay. Does she really?
It's okay. I don't know. It didn't stick with me. Clearly. You know what? Clearly did not. Keep more interesting. No kidding. Let me. Let me pivot. I have to pivot differently. Don't pivot. This is staying in. This is an insight into my friendship with Angela. You stop it. I'm going to stop it. I blame myself. No, no, no. I do. I do. Oh, my God. Angela, you, of course, you're the most thoughtful and wonderful friend. You just forgot that I called it. Thanks, Miss, even though I've been calling it that. for 20 years. Fine. Don't worry about it. Let it go. We're letting it go. Okay. I prefer Chris giving, but is that just me? I think we need to take a survey. I think we need to ask everybody.
I can pivot to Chris giving. Chris giving. Well, that sounds like, it sounds like there's a guy named Chris who's giving me stuff. Pretty generous. Now, Chris giving, I'll remember. No, I'm kidding. Okay. So what are some other traditions, Jenna, that you do to prep for the holidays? Well, my big prep for the holidays, I shop early. Now, I know this about you. I'm so jealous. When I say early, my mom, Ann Fisher, she starts shopping in July.
Wow. And this was, oh, yeah, because she would do a lot of shopping at the Lake of the Ozark outlet malls, which is now gone. But she would always be, like, she'll find little, like, treasures in the summer, and she squirrels them away in her closet. Does she forget about any of them? Yes. Okay. Very often she'll find something in like March when she's doing spring cleaning and then she'll stick it in the mail.
She'll be like, I'm so sorry. I forgot I bought you the scarf. It was a Christmas present. I'm glad she's not a hoarder and I'm glad she didn't keep it because maybe unconsciously she just wanted more stuff for herself. But that's clearly not the case. Good for her. This has rubbed off on me.
And I actually, I find like the Black Friday shopping after Thanksgiving. If I wait that long to get the bulk of my gifts, I feel stressed out. I don't like that. I kind of actually like to shop and get almost all of my shopping done in October and November. You guys, I'm a Christmas Eve shopper. I really am sometimes. I know, I know. You're at the mall just in person.
I feel like ever since high school, I would go into the city in Philadelphia from the burbs and like, you know, deal with all the, there's only one box left. And someone like screaming at someone else in line. Do you like the chaos? Maybe you like throwing some elbows. I didn't think I did. I don't know. I'm just addicted to trouble. I don't know. I don't know. It's bad. I want that on a pillow for you. Well, ladies, I feel like we've covered Cindy's question. Should we go to Maggie M. in Maryland? She sent us a really fun Meredith question. Okay. Hi, office ladies. I love it when you break down fan theories. And I was wondering if you could discuss whether Meredith represents Pam's future if she had married Roy instead of Jim.
Thank you. Have you heard this fan theory? I have not, but I kind of love it. It's sort of amazing, right? And don't you feel like the whole ICE episode was a little bit of a glimpse into Pam's life if she didn't have a supportive husband at home? Because Jim was away.
And you know, Roy would have been totally absent, I think. He would have been on his wave runners. Exactly. with his brother. And her and Meredith really bond. This is true. There's nothing like a little girls just want to have fun karaoke. I know. Kate, I just recently came across a ton of pictures of of you from that episode. Do you know that you went around to every single cast member and took a picture with them? I remember. Yeah. Oh my gosh. I actually have them on my computer. I'm sure some of them were like, it's okay. I don't need my picture with you today. I mean, they are amazing. I want, here's like,
one of my favorites, though, and you'll have to tell us if Chris took this, it's just you playing solitaire, but you have no hair. He might have, yeah. You guys, I don't know if you know, my boyfriend, Chris Hasten, was the photographer on the office, and he was the chief stills guy at NBC for years. He shot a ton of shows, Seinfeld and friends, everything, everything, even the Golden Girls. Look at this one in the conference room. Oh, my God, hilarious. Look at your face. You're like cracking yourself up. I mean, every time I see that bald cap work, it is just masterful. Yeah, I can't believe it. It was crazy.
And the artist that did it, his name is Ed French. He teaches other makeup artists how to do the bald cap because he did the blood vessels. He did like the stubble. Look, he did little tiny moles because we all have moles on our scalp. Yeah. Like the work he did was amazing. Yeah, he's really incredible. I mean, he's done famous, like there's a Star Trek movie from 1980 where there's a bald woman in it.
I can't remember her character's name, but she's on the poster and he did that bald cap. Wow. Yeah, Ed French. He's unbelievable. So, yeah, it was worth the four and a half hours every morning to get into that. Four and a half hours, Kate? And then it took, like, almost three to get out of it. Stop. I didn't realize you were in there. I've new respect for all my sci-fi actor friends.
I have weird makeup every day. So what was your call time then? I never left. I just would sleep. I mean, kind of true. Where you're just like, can I just wear it home at this point? I guess to God, I know it would have been faster. I think it was literally like 345, like 3.35, like it was early or four. Wow.
Yeah, it was early. Yeah, it was really. But, you know, I mean, it was worth it. I didn't want to shave my head for real, so. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. That's all right. Well, how about this, ladies? Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to talk about our favorite, the office holiday memories. I like this idea. Okay. Okay. We are back with Kate. And I'm... I want to chat now about the office holiday memories. Kate, what office holiday moment do you hear about most from fans that has to do with your character on the holidays? Is there a quote? Is there a scene? Well, in the first Christmas episode, there's two. But the first is
my talking head. And people always... They always quote it. Some of it was written and a little bit of it was improvised. And I was really happy that my improv part made it in. Oh, I think we should hear it. Let's hear it. Let's grab it. The deal is that this is my last hurrah because I made a New Year's resolution that I'm not going to drink anymore during the week.
I just added the during the week. You added during the week? I did. Oh my gosh. Kate, that's the singer of it. That's the whole thing. Oh, it's brilliant. We have the best writers in TV, though.
You have to understand. I always think of whenever I improvise on the show and it makes it on, I'm like, oh, because the writers literally tilled the soil. They teed you up, yeah. They laid a carpet. They put a brass band down the path before I got there. And I take two extra steps and that's what happens.
It's so true, though, because we had such a great foundation. Yeah, they just set us up perfectly. So if anything you had in your mind that might work or take it to another level, it was like, it was a dream. It was a dream. So there's that line. And then, of course, the scene where Meredith walks in and takes her top off and Michael Scott takes a picture. That's the one I thought. Oh, my God.
I thought I bet people. Yeah. I'm so happy to hear that in an airport, you guys. Thanks so much. Oh, no. What do they say? How do they, how do they like? Hey, remember when you took your top off in front of my.
Oh, my gosh. Everybody lost in the airport, clearly, Logan. She's like, remember when you take your top off? Yeah. Hey. And my parents are so proud. Angela, what about you? Oh, man.
I mean, my character had a bunch of Christmas-like moments because the party planning committee, right? So, I mean, we already talked about this, but when I throw the ornaments in the parking lot and smash them, people love that. The screech is like insane. You know, here's the thing. The screech was real because they were supposed to give me ornaments. that shatter, like ready to break, like breakable ornaments. And I don't know what happened, but they got the wrong ones, and those were plastic. So the first time I threw it on the ground with everything I had, expecting it to
shatter, it bounced right back up like a tennis ball. And so I couldn't break them. I physically couldn't break them. Is that why you stomp them? That's why I stomp them and shriek because I'm like, f***ing break. And there was a guy on the roof doing the snow. and Charles McDougal was like, are we going to get this shot or not?
Our director was so great. He was so great, but I knew if the ornaments didn't break, it wouldn't make it in. I really wanted that moment to make it in. Totally. And it was such a great moment. Oh my God, it's so, it's chilling.
It's like it's so, and it so leads to that Christmas frustration where it's like you end up being the opposite of what you want to be, which is like happy and merry and kind. It's like there's always, you know, I don't know, I feel like most people have one, especially if you're like a woman, you have a moment where you're like, ugh, why isn't this going working?
Yeah. Yeah. So I think the fact that they bounced and then I had to step on them actually, like, played up the frustration. So good. And then I would say, I have two other ones. One is when my character sings Little Drummer Boy and then Dwight helps her out, that people love Little Drummer Boy, you guys. You just recreated it at the con. I did at the fan convention.
Rain and I did that. And then the quote, people say, the first time someone said it to me, I had forgotten that my character said it. And I was like, what? But I literally had someone say this to me. I'm not going to judge Phyllis for desecrating Christmas. There is one person who will, though, and Phyllis just stuffed him into a drawer. And I was like, I was literally like at the mall. And I was like, what? Phyllis did who, huh? What? Oh my God. But yeah, that's when Phyllis is in charge of the party. And it's a rocking theme. And she shoves my nation. activity scene into my drawer. Oh, my God. Yes. So, yeah, okay, wait, Jenna, what about you? Well, I have one thing that comes back to me every holiday season, and it's this, you know that talking head, Pam, I think she's in the break room, and she says, if you use more than three
pieces of tape to wrap a gift, you're doing it wrong. Oh, wow. And people send me that. It haunts me. When I'm wrapping gifts, I think of this thing that Pam said. And I'm like, I guess I'm doing it wrong because I need more than three pieces of tape. It's ridiculous. Three pieces of tape?
So it's like one on the one end, on the other end and one in the middle. That's it. That's all you're supposed to use. My dad could do it. Oh, wow. My dad, when he wraps a gift, he will line up the paper. He'll cut it so that it's like a seamless transition in the print. Wow.
So that like the magician? What? He's an engineer. Oh. So that matters to him. He wraps all the gifts in the family. My mom buys all the gifts. My dad wraps all the gifts.
That's their partner. That's for Christmas. Literally. I know. My mom is a bow master, guys. Wow. Does she do the homemade bows? Homemade bows.
Oh, wow. She does homemade bows, but she'll do like, she'll get like a red and black plaid bow to go on like the brown parchment so it pops. But then like she gave me one time. She got a little tiny red cardinal bird and made like a little nest and put the red cardinal in the nest on top of the bow. I don't even want to open it. It's so beautiful. Oh, well, your mom did homemade bows.
My dad actually made homemade booze. We've so much a couple. Seriously. We made it through an amazing, amazing eggnog. Like it was lethal. Like a boozy eggnog? But he would make the actual eggnog with the eggs. Like he would do the whole thing.
And he would always give it to the nuns and the priests. And the meanest nuns would be like, oh, Oh, Mr. Flannery. All this is like, we're so happy to see you. We got your gift. I'm like, what did you give them? As a kid, I was like, what? She's got another personality?
What's happening? What's in the eggnog, dad? But it's truly, truly magic. Yeah, totally. Well, listen, speaking of gift wrapping, I had to reach out to Kendra Adachi. You know her as the lazy genius because she has an amazing tradition for wrapping gifts at the holidays that lady I think you're going to like,
especially. Really? Yes. Okay, let's hear it. She sent in an audio clip explaining her holiday gift wrapping tradition. Hey, Jenna and Angela, it's Kendra from the Lazy Genius podcast. Okay, Angela, I heard that you might really like something that I do every Christmas season. So I love giving gifts and we have a large family and I wrap every stocking stuffer because maybe I'm crazy. But the point is there are a lot of gifts. to wrap. Now, I do enjoy wrapping, but it can get monotonous when you're just like in a fever dream of cutting paper and pulling off pieces of tape. So I like to make it more enjoyable. I feel that way about a lot of potentially annoying things. Do something fun while you're doing something less fun.
The fun math is better that way. So here's what I do. Every year when I wrap presents, I watch the entire Lord of the Rings trilogy. It's the only time of the year I watch it. And I look forward to it, kind of to a ridiculous degree every single year. It makes wrapping presents, which sometimes could feel like a chore, especially like when life is busy and the night has finally arrived and like, I just want to relax. But then I remember, oh, wait, I get to be with Aragorn and the rest of them, but really only Aragorn because he's the one I care about. And it just makes this season that much more magical and special because it's the only time
I watched those movies. It's just so fun. And a little birdie told me that maybe you would think that idea is fun as well. Happy holidays, ladies. We'll see you soon. Oh, my gosh. Sam and I were literally like air-high-fiving. Like, that is amazing, Kendra.
That is amazing. Isn't that such a great idea to have this, whatever it is, this movie or this is like a whole movie series. Word Alert. You know it's going to carry you. through all your gift wrapping. I don't think I have enough gift wrapping to get through a trilogy of Lord of the Rings. I mean, also, I have such a new vision of Kendra as she's wrapping a gift for, like, her child and, like, the orcs are like, ah, gah, like, that's amazing.
You know, I used to wait on Peter Jackson and Sean Aston and Orlando when they would come back from their breaks. They would come into the restaurant where I worked, like, the restaurant job I still had and I worked for the first season of the office. Kate Manalini. And they would come in at Breck & Meyer. Like, I remember those guys, so funny. I've talked to Sean Aston about this since, but it's so crazy.
Wow. I'm like, what are you guys doing? They're like, eh, we're filming something in Australia. Filming something. Yeah. What the, I mean? Just a huge, massive trilogy. We don't even know we're making Christmas better, but we're making it better.
See, that's what I love about the office. Like, people love the office episodes. Like, we really have a contribution to Christmas at our own weird, strange, wonderful way. We do. I've had people tell me, I'm sure you guys have heard this too, that at Christmas time, they rewatch the Office Christmas episodes. Yes. Yeah, there's a DVD with just the just the holidays on it. Oh, I didn't even know that. It came out a while ago. I'm sure you can find it on eBay or something. Really? Where it's just the holiday episodes. Oh, wow. That's pretty smart. I know, right? You know, speaking of like just a compilation like that, so when we were prepping this
episode. I was like looking up the different Christmas episodes, just kind of refresh my memory. And there is a compilation on YouTube titled, Are You Ready for This, Michael Scott Ruining the Holidays for 40 Minutes Straight. So if you grab all the moments where Michael Scott is ruining your holiday, it equals 40 minutes. Forty minutes. You can watch all 40 minutes. It's amazing. I would add this. If you're an office fan at the holiday time, if you want to watch 40 minutes of Michael, I'm just going to play you the first minute and a half, just so you get a feel for what you're in for. Okay. Are you ready?
Yeah. I'm the real thing. Sit down on my lap and there will be no doubt. Oh, okay. No, it's not, it's not like penis-wise. Christmas is canceled. You can't cancel a holiday. Give it up, Stanley, and you will lose New Year's.
What does that mean? Jim, take New Year's away from Stanley. Michael, what's going on? Carol and I split up amicably. And I just don't think it would be appropriate to celebrate under the circus. Will they still air Rudolph? That's not fair.
Are we going to cancel tonica as well? Fine! Have your party. Just no guests. But we invited guests. Well, you know what, fellas? All of your guests would have probably canceled at the last minute.
Anyway, leaving your life a stupid rotten mess. Okay. Here's Santa! Hey, little girl! What would you like for Christmas? Ooh, you have been a very naughty girl, I see. Michael, we already have a Santa, Phyllis. What the hell is going on?
Phyllis? Jim, Phyllis is Santa? Yeah. Phyllis. Yeah, I told her a long time ago she could do it. Take it back. That is absurd. No. No!
No! Such a child. That is just a minute and a half. There's 40 minutes of him ruining the holidays. Okay, well, ladies, we also spent a ton of time together on set during the holidays. We would sometimes work right up until the actual real holiday. And we even traded gifts sometimes. And I just thought we could share some of our personal holiday memories that we've spent together over the years.
Well, season one, we didn't make it to Christmas. That's right. Yeah, there was no Christmas episode until season two. But you and I went to the dollar store and got Halloween decorations because we worked until through November. Remember that? Yes, I do. On the trailers?
Yes, we decorated the trailers with little cobwebs and spiders. And then it rained and it was very sad. Yeah, and it was gross. And I think it just like was annoying people because this crap was hanging off their trailers. Take the trash out of the trailers, please, ladies, before you leave. I know. I know. Well, Kate, we were talking about one of the first gifts we got from a cast
member, and we thought it was at Christmas, but it was actually a wrap gift that you made. It was, and I'll tell you why. Okay, so this is before you could get anything with the logo that said Dunder Mifflin on it. So I took something off, like a pad off the, or a piece of paper off the set, and I went to Kinko's, and I copied a bunch, and I bought white votive candles, which, you know, I went to 12 years of Catholic school. You guys, I always learned, like, if you want something to work out, you have to pray. So lighting a candle is a wonderful. thing to do. I mean, we do it in the church all the time. So it was an intention candle. And I told everybody. So I literally was up the night before, like, I bought like a case of these white
votive candles. And I literally just glued the dundermifflin on each one. And I handed it to each person. I didn't wrap it. I just like, here, light it and let it burn. We got to come back next year. We got to come back. Like that was my thing about it. Yeah. I actually still have mine. I have mine. Oh my God. I have mine. I love that you guys saw. Okay. So to me, it's like you just, even if it's not your religion, like I feel like if it brings goodwill and somebody has, you know, an intention that's positive for you, why not? You know, why can't? Kate, after I got my breast cancer diagnosis, before I even had my surgery, I was in that place where I had my diagnosis and I was waiting to start my treatment. I was also raised Catholic.
I'm not a practicing Catholic anymore, but that stuff doesn't leave you, right? Right. So I went to a little chapel in Santa Fe, New Mexico, where they have the Holy Dirt. Yes. People take pilgrimages from all over the world to this chapel to get this holy dirt. I got the holy dirt. I lit a candle. I prayed to the saint who helps you. St. Jude, who's the patron saint of loss causes. The patron saint of cancer. There's a patron saint of cancer. And now I can't remember his name. So I lit a candle, prayed to the patron saint of cancer, got the dirt. And it was very powerful. And it is in the power of prayer and the power of Ritual. Yes. And something collectively positive. That's really what it is. Just, you know. And so I don't want to take responsibility completely for us coming back season two. But maybe, but maybe your candle. You know, I mean, you know, you guys know, my mom has her Tuesday Bible study and my mom's always like, Angie, want us to pray for anything? And I'm like, yes. And I will call her up with whatever it is. Like when we were going to maybe do this podcast, I was like, mom, Jen and I are taking a big swing here. Can you and the ladies pray? about it. And she was like, well, if you come in agreement with me. So we all, like, I mean, I believe in, I believe in prayer. I do. I do. Even if it's just something you do for yourself. Absolutely. You know, to reset yourself. Kate, you got the office on season two.
Well, I heard that, but I thought, you know, I'll bet nobody else is going to give this gift. I was trying to be original. So, yeah. And it's true, though, because I think that was the first Dundermifflin anything I have. And that's why we still, we kept them. Yeah. Yeah. It was the first thing with the logo on it. I could probably be arrested if the show didn't go, and I actually created something. No. All right, everybody, I can't believe I'm going to say this, but our time is coming to an end. We have one final question.
What? I didn't even get to talk about being dragged into rehab by Michael Scott. Oh, well, wait, that's, but that's, please. Please, wait, wait. Before we get to our final question, will you please discuss being dragged into rehab by Michael Scott? It's truly a brilliant scene, Kate. You are brilliant in it. All the trash.
Oh, my gosh. That was one of the only... Okay, so in Moroccan Christmas, when Michael Scott pretends like he's taking Meredith to get a drink at a bar, but instead drags her to rehab, that whole scene in the parking lot was completely improvised. That's the only completely improvised scene I got to do on the show. And I feel like not a lot of us had an opportunity to do that. And I think the intention was, because I think Paul Feig was a director, they were going to do like a voiceover over the whole thing. So I don't know if they even intended on keeping it. Right.
We're not going to use this dialogue, say whatever you want. Right. But they ended up using a lot of it, which I was like, I can't really about. But I just remember also there were two stunt people dressed like us, like Michael Scott and Meredith, out of the corner of my eye, just in case one of us got hurt. Because we really didn't plan what we were doing. The chase was not really planned. I mean, I knew he was going to throw trash cans at me. Oh, I was throwing trash cans at him.
What am I saying? But it was all like a weird. we had this whole negotiation and running thing. And I was screaming so much, literally when he was dragging me, once we got into the hospital, Kelly Cantley was the attendant at the rehab center. That's right. Our assistant director played that.
First AD, and it was the only time I think she's ever been on an episode. And I literally lost my voice by the end of that. And it was totally worth it. It was totally worth it. But that whole thing where I'm negotiating or Meredith's saying like, wait, wait, wait, wait a minute. Totally. I was like, I was so happy that Paul Feig,
he's like, do that again. He kept asking me to repeat certain things that I would say. I'm like, oh, so, yeah, I just saw Paul Feig last week at a women in film event. And we were just, like, you know, just totally reminiscing about how wonderful it was to work together on the office. Yeah. But aren't you so thankful of all the directors, it was Paul Feig? Because, of course, Paul gave you all of that agency to just, like, go for it. And then he supported you when you found a nugget that was really good.
Totally. All right. Are we ready for our final question? Yeah, here it is. If you had to attend one Dunder Mifflin holiday party, which one would you pick? And now we're going to give you the choices. We're going to give you the choices. But basically, you're looking at a party either thrown by Angela, Pam, Phyllis, Jim and Dwight are Andy. Jenna, why don't you list them off? Here they are. Would you want to go to Christmas party? Angela's in charge of Christmas, and you're going to have a real sad Yankee swap. Do you want to attend a Benny Hanuk Christmas. This is the dueling Christmas parties. You have Pam and Karen versus Angela. Marocan Christmas. This is the one that Phyllis is in charge of. This ends in Meredith's intervention. And burnt hair. And yes. Hair on fire. Yeah. While she's belly dancing. Thank you. There's also secret Santa. This was Jim and Dwight's holiday party. We had dueling Santas. You had both Phyllis and Michael as Santa and Michael as Jesus.
I was sitting on Phyllis's lap when Kevin was sitting on Michael Scott. slap at the same time. Oh, that's so great. So great. Trying not to laugh. You could attend a classy Christmas. This is when Pam was in charge of a regular Christmas that got turned into a bigger, fancier party to impress Holly. Michael has kind of a meltdown, and there's the insane snowball fight with Jim and Dwight. There's Christmas wishes. Andy's in charge of Christmas. Dwight and Jim prank each other. Robert California announces his divorce. That's always fun at a party. Or, finally, Dwight's Christmas, he throws the traditional shrewd holiday party with bell schnickle. And you are either impish or admirable.
And you get swatted at with a bunch of sticks. Which Christmas party would you like to attend? Well, this is like picking your favorite child. You really cannot do it. Can you? It's really just. I don't know. Some of these children are much worse than the others.
But I will actually say, I had the most. fun shooting Moroccan Christmas, but I will say a Christmas party, the first one, was my favorite because we were in New Territory for the show, for Dunner-R-Mill. It was just, it was just, you know, remember, the big tree that didn't fit? Yes, they had to get the biggest tree. And then the Yankee Swap, which was endless but fantastic. That group scene, yeah. There was like a, like a, like a, like a, like a, like a, like a, like a, the weight of a brick. Like, that's how old this episode is. I know, the old took. I'm with you, Kate. I'm with you because I felt like that group scene of us all in a circle handing out the gifts is one of my favorite group scenes we ever did on the show. Everyone had a
moment and it was just amazing. I'm going to go another way, guys. Where are you going? I'm going with a Benihana Christmas, the dueling Christmas parties. I just loved, because we had the singing and everything, and I loved that in the conference room. Pam and Karen had booze. It was, yeah, it was like two parties. You can go to two parties. But Angela had, I think, some good food. You had some good, like, treats and cookies and things.
Yeah. So I don't know. If I had to attend a party just as a guest, I think I might like to show up at the dueling Christmas parties. If I had to go back in time and re-experience shooting a Christmas episode, then I think, gosh, that's very difficult. But then I'd have to go to the original Christmas party. Okay, so same.
So if me, Angela, me, Kinsey, Martin, wanted to revisit, it would be Yankee Swap because I just want to live in that group scene again, just selfishly. But if I'm just a partygoer, I think I would pick Secret Santa because I love the idea of two Santas in just. Jesus all at the same party. Yeah, that sounds like a great party. That was my runner-up. Right. I'm still like, I think Meredith is all in for the first Christmas episode, and so is Kate. Well, Kate, thank you so much for being on our holiday chit-chat episode. The folks at Macy sent a gift card for you. They sure did. Here you go, Kate. Happy shopping from the folks at Macy's. Thank you so much, Macy's. I didn't get you anything. I'm so sorry. I feel really, I didn't buy Macy's anything.
So sorry. Oh, Kate, this is so fun. So fun. I mean, Kate, I do kind of feel like I need you to lead us in a Christmas carol. Yes. Are they free? Can we have one? I know a bunch that are free.
You know so? I'm trying to think of like something from the office. And the only thing I can think of is come they told me by rapa, da da da da da da. That was still an Angela's song. Thank you guys. And thank you to the folks at Macy's for supporting office ladies. We love these holiday bonus episodes. We love you guys.
Kate, thanks for coming in. Thank you so much, you guys. I love you, Angela. Yes. You guys. And can we, are we going to sing our way out of this or what? Okay. Oh, come let us adore him.
Oh, come let us adore him. Oh, come let us adore him. Mr. Michael Scott. Boy, would Michael have loved that. He would have. Perfect. Happy holidays, everybody. Happy holidays. Happy holidays.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley-Eanzeley. Bubbleco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rupertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.